competing for 20 years and that hasn't
happened and even if it did
why is that so bad
it's not fair it's not fair uh you know
it's not fair okay why do men think they
should have a say in women's sports and
women's issues you are all about women's
rights until it's the right to our own
athletic division i played basketball
volleyball and i ran track in college
i'm about five eleven and a half six
foot tall and i was short i had a hard
time recruiting for colleges because i
was short when it comes to women i'm in
the top one percent of height i'm also
very strong for a girl but amongst men i
would be in the top 15 percent that
means out of every 100 trans men that
transitioned i would be shorter than 15
of them that is an advantage i have
against women and i would no longer have
against men not to mention that men have
a larger lung capacity thicker bone
density wrist strength and there's even
more disrespectful because this guy is
trying to make the argument that oh who
cares if
you know a trans person won
a silly race um excuse me
we worked our whole entire lives for
that i've been playing volleyball since
i was in fifth grade in basketball since
i was in second grade and you're telling
me that if i make it to the college
level and have the opportunity to win an
ncaa championship the pinnacle of all of
my hard work and success that i just
should be cool with
someone transitioning over and taking
that spot i've said it before and i'll
say it again men shouldn't have a say in
these issues and they shouldn't be
allowed in our division